according to ABC News President Trump
will sign an executive order today to
investigate voter fraud the executive
order would create a commission staffed
by Vice President Mike Pence and Kansas
secretary of state Kris Kobach to
investigate election integrity ABC News
reports quote the Commission which will
include Republicans and Democrats will
be tasked with studying vulnerabilities
in u.s. voting systems and potential
effects on improper voting fraudulent
voter registrations and fraudulent
voting according to one official with
knowledge of the announcement this is a
fine notion voter fraud is indeed a
serious problem and threatens election
integrity
despite Democratic claims to the
contrary more specifically the
possibility of widespread voter fraud
remains a problem even though evidence
of actual fraudulent ballots being cast
is relatively scanty as the daily wire
has reported in 2012 the Pew Research
Center found the following there were
almost 24 million active voter
registrations in the United States
either invalid or inaccurate almost 2
million dead americans were still in the
active voting list 12 million voter
records riddled with incorrect addresses
or other errors almost 2.75 million
voters were registered in over one state
and it does not take widespread voter
fraud to shift an election the passage
of Obamacare which relied on the
replacement of Republican senator Norm
Coleman of Minnesota with Al Franken
rested on a three hundred twelve vote
recount margin in favor of Franken
according to the Minnesota majority a
conservative watchdog group quote at
least 341 convicted felons voted in
Minneapolis as Hennepin County the
state's largest another 52 voted
illegally in st. Pauls Ramsey County the
state's second largest Dan McGrath head
of Minnesota majority says the only
conclusive matches were included in the
group's total number of felons voting in
those two counties alone exceeds mr.
Franken victory margin the same held
true in 2004 s Washington State
gubernatorial election with Democrat
christine Gregoire defeating Republican
Dino Rossi by a hundred and twenty nine
votes some 1,400 felons voted illegally
in that election at least 55 thousand
ballots were enhanced and the Secretary
of State certified election results in
at least five counties or more votes
were cast and there were voters
according to Bob Williams of the
Evergreen Freedom Foundation a single
vote cast illegally means someone else's
vote has been cancelled out so it's
about time we looked at voter fraud with
that said the media will now attempt to
quash any real investigation into voter
fraud based on president Trump's wild
over statement of voter fraud during the
2016 election cycle Trump announced
after his electoral college victory in
he'd actually won the popular vote
- except for three million votes cast
illegally for Hillary said well you can
never find you know they're going to be
no matter what numbers we come up with
they're gonna be lack of paypal that did
things we're not going to find out about
that's what Trump said in January but we
will find out because we need a better
system where that can't happen that
means that Trump's rhetoric will once
again smear a good cause and allow the
media to reopen an idiotic conversation
with Trump about whether he believes you
on the popular road and because Trump is
pathologically incapable of avoiding a
perceived slight he'll take the bait get
ready for two more weeks of talk about
how Trump was actually jobs in the
popular vote even though we should be
focusing on the real necessity of voter
ID and cleansing voter rolls in order to
draw Democrats Trump is apparently
including language about voter
suppression - even though there's no
proof of voter suppression across the
country whatsoever that will get
Democrats on board and allow them to
propagandize about how voter ID actually
prevents people from voting so bottom
line
it's good the Trump is looking at voter
fraud it's too bad that Donald Trump is
the one is actually doing it i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
oh it's Urinetown USA because the weeks
are everywhere they're everywhere ever
that everything has opened up the skies
have opened the leaks are pouring down
and now we have many theories as to why
FBI director James Comey was actually
fired but most of the evidence seems to
support you guessed it
my theory from yesterday as to why it is
that James Comey was fired we'll talk
about all of that in just one second but
first we want to say thank you for
sponsors over at policy genius.com so if
you are somebody who is in need of life
insurance and let's face it if you are
alive and you have debt or if you're
alive and you don't have debt and you're
afraid that your family will have data
if you die you need policy genius.com
you can save over 40% on other life
insurance policies when you go to policy
genius.com if placed over five billion
dollars in life insurance for people
like you I myself have life insurance I
think my company has life insurance on
me as well a good thing that I get along
with my company so they can't kill me
but in any case policy genius.com will
make sure you have life insurance you
should as a responsible human being you
should have life insurance so that
whether it's your spouse or your
children or your parents people around
you aren't left financially unstable
because of your death and that's why you
need life insurance go over to policy
genius com they are the best online life
insurance marketplace they cut out the
middleman
it's basically an open bidding system
for people to give you the best policies
they have a license customer service
team as well to help you find the best
policy at the best price and there's no
interest in upselling it's just about
bringing you the best policy at the best
price just for you you're going to save
over 40% off other life insurance
policies go to policy genius comm today
and get that 40% discount off of other
prices for life insurance because that's
just what their competitive system does
policy genius Campillo li cy g en i us
calm policy genius calm no jargon no
sales pressure no hassle and that's
going to make sure that you have life
insurance that you desperately need and
a huge person having 30 percent of US
households don't have life insurance
that's absurd you should have life
insurance and you should make sure that
your loved ones do as well policy
genius.com okay so obviously the news of
the day continues to be the fallout from
the firing of FBI director james comey
and now we have leaks aplenty so they're
really two big stories that came out
maybe three that have come out full of
leaks about Trump firing Comey
and one thing is absolutely clear the
original explanation for why the
administration fired coming
and hold any waters the original
explanation was you know the set PD
Attorney General Ron Rosenstein he
showed up 14 days ago and many decided
you know Comey had to go so he wrote us
a memo unprompted in which he said that
Comey had to go and we took his advice
and we fired James Comey that's Horseman
or everyone who was Horseman or from the
first day
the problem with rolling out a bad story
is now it makes people believe the worst
when you say something that isn't true
it makes people immediately jump to the
worst possible conclusion as opposed to
the more realistic but not so great
conclusion which is probably what
actually happen so it's pretty clear now
that Ron Rosenstein was not the guy
behind the firing there have been
multiple reports that Trump basically
had decided decided to fire Comey last
week and then he called Ron Rosenstein
and Attorney General Jeff Sessions into
his office and said come up with some
sort of letter that's a pretext for
firing him and Rosenstein did what a
good soldier is supposed to do he wrote
this letter apparently there was a
report yesterday the DOJ is now denying
that Rosenstein actually threatened to
resign yesterday because he was so
ticked off that the Trump White House
seemed to be blaming him for commis
Alistair bottom line this was handled
about as badly as you can handle any
issue like this I was listening to Dana
Perino and Chris Tyrells podcast which
is worth listening to and Dana who knows
a hell of a lot about White House
communications she was saying the people
she feels bad for in all of this are the
members of the White House
communications staff were given about
half an hour notice that this was
happening maybe and then were forced to
scramble and then Trump gets pissed off
when they don't have a good cover story
which is his fault because he was the
one who forced them to scramble but the
real question remains why exactly was he
fired so the story from the White House
continues to be he was fired because he
did a bad job so here's Sarah Huckabee
Sanders who's supposed to be good at
this right she's supposed to be better
than Sean Spicer as there are rumors
yesterday that Trump hates how Sean
Spicer has handled it so he's thinking
about firing Spicer to everybody is
basically on the hook with Trump if you
do something he doesn't like he'll fire
you all he demands is loyalty which is
one of the stories we'll talk about
there's a story that James Comey was
fired because he refused to guarantee
Trump his personal loyalty in any case
here is Sarah Huckabee Sanders making an
insane case as to why James Comey was
fired I think also having a letter like
the one that he received and having that
conversation that outlined the basic
just atrocities in
circumventing the chain of command in
the Department of Justice any person of
legal mind and authority knows what a
big deal that is particularly in the
Department of Justice particularly for
somebody like the Deputy Attorney
General who has been part of the Justice
Department for thirty years and none of
this makes any sense first of all you
don't use the word atrocities about
legal errors okay atrocity is like for
atrocity is for like the Holocaust or My
Lai or Syria gassing people atrocity is
not he went out in public and said
something about about Hillary Clinton
Loretta Lynch like that I'm sorry it
doesn't rise to the level atrocity
that's just silly the case that she's
making is calm he's bad at his job
yes Comey was bad at his job yes he's
been saying that for a year mm-hmm
that's right it was me so I've been
saying for your James Comey is
absolutely crappy at his job but the
question isn't why he was fired the
question is why he was fired now and the
answer clearly is not something that
happened last July so that story has no
veracity whatsoever Jake Tapper presents
another story so now you've got a bunch
of anonymous sources leaking and here's
the thing to know about anonymous
sources they're anonymous we don't know
who they are and we don't know what
their agenda is
and we don't know whether they have any
specialized knowledge as to why Comey
was fired we don't know whether they're
speaking from personal knowledge what's
actually going on in the investigation
or whether they are speaking based on
speculation at the FBI
you know anonymous sources are useful
and you have to use them in journalism
because a lot of people are afraid of
speaking with their name on the record
because they're afraid they're going to
get fired for it so anonymous sources
our common use but the problem is when
you have a thousand anonymous sources
coming forward you sort of have to take
everything with a grain of salt until
further information is confirmed the
media is not doing that Jake Tapper
yesterday reported what an anonymous
source had said about why Comey was
fired now if this is true then Trump
will be impeached okay but it's not true
then where is it even coming from there
are two reasons why President Trump
fired Comey one commis refusal to
provide the president with any sort of
assurance of personal loyalty and to the
fact that the FBI's investigation into
possible prompting collusion with Russia
and the 2016 election that's still not
only an active investigation it's
actually accelerating so basically the
theory here is that Comey wouldn't
provide Trump with his assurance of
personal loyalty you can see some of
that in Trump's letter right the
that Comey had told him that he was off
the hook three times but that he
wouldn't go out publicly and say the
Trump was off the hook three times or
even one time so that is actually
there's some brass key to that second
claim is the one that matters and that's
the one Democrats are hopping on today
this is a Democrats coming out and
saying that the decision to fire Comey
is really about obstructing the Russian
investigation now here's the part that's
crazy about this
there's an entire FBI out there it's
still doing the investigation there's no
evidence whatsoever that the
investigation will actually be quashed
in fact what Trump has now done is he
brought more focus to the investigation
not less focused an investigation these
are through incompetence or stupidity or
because he didn't care but whatever the
whatever the bottom line is more people
now care about the Trump Rush
investigation than cared about it two
days ago so the idea that he killed the
investigation is just silly towns
there's a lot of call for a special
prosecutor special prosecutor I think is
a bad idea the reason a special
prosecutor is a bad idea is because once
you put a special prosecutor on the case
the special prosecutor will stay there
and dig and dig and dig until they find
something whether or not it is really
related to the key components of the
story so Kenneth Starr will continue to
dig on Clinton until he comes up with
Lewinsky and Patrick Fitzgerald will
continue to dig on the Valerie Plame
scandal until he comes up with Scooter
Libby who's not even involved in the
Valerie Plame scandal you put a special
prosecutor on this thing and that person
will just dig in dig and dig and dig
until they come up with something that
is not even related and just cast a
cloud of suspicion over everything the
best possible outcome here is for Trump
to appoint somebody at the FBI who's
considered sort of bipartisan who isn't
going to be just a Trump Lackey if you
points Chris Christie or Rudy Giuliani
people are going to scream bloody murder
as well they ought if you appoint
somebody like Mike Lee was suggesting
Merrick garland who is you recall was
was Barack Obama's last Supreme Court
nomination if you appoint somebody who
has credibility the Democrats it's going
to be very hard for Democrats to make
the claim that this was all a giant
cover-up a crazy attempt by Trump to to
kill the Russia investigation but
Democrats are out over their skis today
they're trying to push for impeachment
without any sort of evidence here's
Richard Blumenthal a guy that that Trump
is now calling again I guess he's he's
saying that he's a he accused him of
lying about his war service which is
true but Richard Blumenthal has become
sort of the bentonville AR for Trump and
here he is senator from Connecticut
talking to Anderson Cooper it is a
looming constitutional crisis because it
involved
potential confrontation as did Watergate
between the president and other branches
of government and it may well produce
another United States versus Nixon on a
subpoena that went to the United States
Supreme Court it may well produce
impeachment proceedings although we're
very far from that possibility and right
now the president has not been charged
and there is a investigation underway
which should be given the kind of
integrity and independence that it
deserves because it is way out over his
skis you're talking about Nixon talking
about impeachment this is not like
Watergate okay in Watergate Richard
Nixon fired the special prosecutor who'd
been set up in order to investigate
Watergate and then the Attorney General
he basically said to the Attorney
General you fire this guy and the
Attorney General said no I'm not going
to fire this guy then went to the Deputy
Attorney General I said you fire this
guy and said I'm not going to fire this
guy so trauma but so so Nixon fired all
three of them and the bottom line is
that it is the bottom line is that this
is not like that right I mean the
Attorney General and the Deputy Attorney
General both recommended the economy be
fired again this is not obstructing the
investigation by any evidence that I can
tell yet the Democrats are still going
nuts over this Cory Booker who has
presidential ambitions he's going
crazier than anybody else I've seen
senator from New Jersey say great
screenshot there guys he is saying that
is saying that the Russians are coming
Donald Trump clearly has not taken this
seriously in what should be a Paul
Revere moment for our country where
people are talking about the Russians
are coming there intending not only to
attack this past election less intending
to continue this behavior what will our
response be and right now it's been
wholly unsatisfactory yet from this
administration okay so this still leaves
out the question again he has no answers
as to what exactly he suspect is going
on or what evidence he has that any of
this is happening basically the
Democrats are making hay while the Sun
shines they see that this is an
opportunity to bash Trump and so they're
going to go ahead and do it I will say
that there they're basically a few
different stories today as to why it is
that Trump fired economy and all of them
agree with my theory yesterday's my
theory yesterday to restate was that
Trump fired Comey because he was pissed
economy that simple he wasn't angry at
call me because Comey wasn't coming out
and just saying that Trump was innocent
in the Russian investigation even if
other people were still under
investigation like NSA Michael Flynn and
former campaign manager
mana for so you stick to KO me for not
doing that it now appears that he was
also take to call me because ko me was
not taking his wiretapping crap
seriously and he wasn't investigating
leaks or whatever and so he felt that
was a misuse of resources and he wants
an FBI director who's going to who's
going to try and track down all of his
conspiracy theories about the Obama
administration again should the FBI be
spending time on finding out who leaked
the name Michael Flynn to the press
absolutely they should and so I don't
think that's completely unfair but for
Trump to get angry economy because Comey
was not paying attention to his stupid
wiretapping allegations that's absurd
because they were stupid wiretapping
allegations but that's exactly what the
Washington Post is reporting quote Trump
had long questioned commis loyalty and
judgment I was infuriated by what he
viewed as the directors lack of action
in recent weeks on leaks from within the
federal government by last weekend he
had made up his mind Comey had to go the
president had already decided to fire
Comey according to this person but in
the meeting several White House
officials said Trump gave sessions and
Rosenstein a directive to explain in
writing the case against Comey the
President had already decided to fired
calling and call me according to this
person and bottom line is that they
decided that they were going to come up
with this pretext for firing call me but
what actually pissed off Trump one
Kuhlman was on TV too much to call me
refused to say the Trump was innocent
three Comey wouldn't provide his
personal loyalty guarantee to President
Trump which is just insane the FBI
director should never be forced to
provide a personal loyalty guarantee to
any president that is not his job again
all of this reflects badly on Trump none
of it suggests that Trump is actually in
the pay of the Russians or in collusion
with the Russians now with that said
there was a media report from The Wall
Street Journal it really is kind of a
bombshell and says in the weeks before
Trump fired FBI director James Comey a
federal investigation into potential
collusion between Trump associates and
the Russian government was heating up as
mr. Comey became increasingly occupied
with the probe mr. Comey started
receiving daily instead of weekly
updates on the investigation beginning
at least three weeks ago according to
people with knowledge of the matter and
progress of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation probe mr. Comey was
concerned by information showing
possible evidence of collusion according
to these people so this would be the
biggest bombshell of course is the idea
that there's actually something dirty
going on and Trump covered it up all we
have is this anonymous source saying
that Comey was concerned about that but
we don't have any evidence that that was
actually happening there's also a report
from McClatchy today that the FBI led
probe into whether Russian influence
operations help put Trump in the White
House is on the nightstand
and could easily veer into either of two
distinct directions one possibility is
investigators will feel galvanized by
Trump's abrupt firing of FBI director
Comey and borough even deeper into the
probe or with the FBI temporary rudder a
temporarily rudderless Trump loyalists
in the Justice Department could put the
brakes on the investigation in multiple
ways so all of this does not speak well
of the way that this was done again none
of it provides evidence that all this is
done there is a bigger problem here by
the way and the bigger problem comes in
that same Washington Post piece this
deep long piece about why Trump fired
call me and it was buried down in the
piece and it's actually a big story it
says quote many employees of the FBI
said they were furious about the firing
saying the circumstances of commis
dismissal did more damage to the FBI's
independence than anything Comey didn't
his three plus years in the job one
intelligence official who works on
ruspin Russian espionage matters said
they were more determined than ever to
pursue such cases another sent commis
firing and the subsequent comments from
the White House our attacks then won't
soon be forgotten Trump had quote
essentially declared war on a lot of
people at the FBI one official said I
think there will be a concerted effort
to respond over time in kind this is
dangerous
when the intelligence community Trump's
been saying this for a long time and
he's actually right about it when the
intelligence community decides that it
is their job to take down Trump because
they don't like what Trump is doing that
is dangerous and that is a problem and
the fact is that two things can be true
at once one from handled the bakoma
firing absolutely badly it looks really
a lot worse than it probably is and to
the intelligence community
does not have the wherewithal to begin
saying that we're now going to ask Trump
because we don't like what you did to
Comey okay that's dangerous that is a
branch and that is a coup that is it
that is an attempt inside government to
get rid of the sitting presidents of the
United States and that is unacceptable
under all of these circumstances I want
to talk more about this let's talk about
the fallout and why this actually
matters for the Republicans why
shouldn't Republicans just blow it off
say this is overblown hit it Cecilia
this is just Democrats talking too much
why Republicans should take the
seriously over at daily wired.com so $8
a month gets you a subscription to daily
wire.com you can watch the rest of the
show if you sign up right now you can be
part of the mailbag will be taking live
questions in the mailbag today plus if
you get in the annual subscription you
get a free copy of the Arroyo jeremy
boring fascinating film set on the
southern border it's a modern action
Western about Rancher trying to protect
his property from drug cartels using his
ranch as a thoroughfare for drugs and
trafficking and check it out over at
daily wire.com or if you just want to
listen to the podcast later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud and give us a
listen in the rating we always
appreciate it make sure that you
subscribe we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
Oh